welcome to hannity big breaking news
tonight on all fronts all over the
country
matter of fact thanks to our attorney
general that would be bill barr
and john durham the deep state reckoning
is now
fully underway you were wondering when
we would get to this point we are now
the question for director
ray tonight of the fbi how do you wish
to be remembered director
it's time to go all in the attorney
general's there where are you
now after bombshell developments in the
setup case against lieutenant general
michael flynn
we now have two lawmakers are now
calling on the fbi director to
investigate
the troubling politicizing and
misconduct surrounding comey's fbi
comey himself that have a full complete
comprehensive report tonight
also ahead joe biden the dnc the mob and
your media
all panicking over biden's me too
scandal and the fact that he doesn't
have a slow pitch anymore
now a partial reopening also tonight is
underway
in at least 23 states many more soon
online to open but outrage is growing as
americans are voicing their rightful
concerns about what are draconian
measures
being taken by a handful of governors
and resistance to opening the country
safely
we have a full report on that and a
breaking new report
you can't make this up see that right
there that that is called the giant
asian murder hornet and it's coming to
america
it's actually here well and it's scary
we'll explain first
we turn to our top story tonight brand
new filing today
flynn attorney sydney powell who will
join us in a few moments disclosing
that flynn's previous lawyers just
discovered
oh let's see thousands of pages of newly
unearthed fbi documents handwritten
notes
that have just been turned over to the
presiding judge that's emmett sullivan
in this case
and based on a previous release we
already know how
the corrupt politically motivated
actions by
a very few high-ranking members of
comey's fbi
nearly destroyed the life of general
flynn in many ways they did
they hurt him they hurt his family he's
bankrupt he had to sell his house
and he wouldn't lie oh by the way in
2016 and 17 while most federal agents
were busy protecting this country from
terrorists drug cartels
violent gang members other serious
threats well we had
a few high-ranking officials in comey's
politicized fbi
they were more concerned with what we
now know to be
a sick twisted political vendetta
against donald trump and everyone around
him and basically what was
an attempt at a soft coup after they
didn't succeed
in helping prevent him from getting
elected they were helping hillary
now lieutenant general michael flynn
this is one part
of a much larger political hit job now
here's what we know before president
trump was sworn into office
an aggressive fbi investigation found
absolutely
zero derogatory material on general
flynn after they had investigated
they knew the russia collusion narrative
was a complete and total bs they knew it
completely agents well they said all
right let's close this case
against flynn and that is until strzok
and comey
all got involved and yes being led by
the super patriot james comey
they sent two agents to ambush the brand
new
national security adviser day for the
trump administration
and those quote always chaotic days of
any new administration
mccabe had just that day advised flynn
oh you don't need to have a lawyer
president no not at all
and the agents at the well direction he
sent them
his own words jim comey ambush general
flynn
those agents even still concluded flynn
was honest no deception he was being
truthful in the following days we now
know that peter strzok
significantly altered the contents of
what we now know to be our 302s
that is and by the way lisa page edited
them again
great couple and boom just like that
they invented a crime
they accused flynn of lying remember
last week he said well what is our
purpose here what is our aim is it
to get him to commit perjury to get it
into admission
to get him prosecuted to get him fired
remember
the only the only goals of the fbi in
the department of justice should be
justice
equal application equal you know
use of our laws equal justice under the
law our constitutional rights
ultimately they forced him to plead
guilty why because they threatened to go
after his son and put his son in jail
and after causing him to go bankrupt he
lost his house and he couldn't pay his
legal bills
and by the way in the end they hit a
mountain of what we now know was
exculpatory
material from flint flynn's legal team
and to this day there never was
any evidence whatsoever that flynn
was ever colluding with any foreign
government or that he ever lied to the
fbi
they thought just the opposite he was
never compromised in any way and what
happened to him was nothing more than a
political persecution
and yeah a soft coup attempt by james
comey's fbi
now that's my assessment and it wasn't
just flynn by the way
george papadopoulos he was on my radio
show today roger stone will be on this
week
carter page paul manafort yeah he's not
doing well he's not well
physically he's in prison what do they
all have in common
donald trump and because of their
connection to trump well they were all
spied on interrogated their records
examined with the fine-tooth comb even
cases that had been closed they
purposely reopened it
for the purpose of hurting donald trump
and by the way in two cases you have
heavily armed swat teams this is the
roger stone raid
and paul manafort they just didn't have
the cnn cameras tipped off there raiding
their homes
in the dark of night non-violent process
crimes in stone's case 29 guys and
tactical gear and frogmen
and cnn cameras just happen to be there
by the way the ig
has accused comey mccabe and others of
themselves committing these process
crimes and the need to have an
investigation into such and possible
referrals
so now the question is for the fbi
director
because we know that the attorney
general barr we know john durham
they forced this issue on general flynn
they pushed to get this information
out there was much resistance
unfortunately
where we don't quite know yet so that
would mean director ray
why didn't you get this out to us you've
been there a long time
now my sources sadly you're telling me
that the damning new flynn evidence
well that was released was released
perhaps
perhaps we're going to get to the bottom
of it in spite of director wray he has a
lot to answer for tonight
he needs to come to the american people
director ray
did you protect the deep state
infrastructure now do you want to
restore
this is his challenge america's faith
and what is the world not just the u.s i
have
this is the pin right here there's an
fbi pin right here i see
this is for solidarity with the 99
percent of courageous
law-abiding good law enforcement the
premier law enforcement institution in
the world
and they deserve their good name back
because they do
the right thing they protect us and they
risk their lives
or directorate do you want justice to
prevail
or are you more interested in protecting
the likes of comey and struck
and mccabe and other well former
corrupt individuals now two lawmakers
congressman jim jordan and congressman
mike johnson
they're pressuring director ray to do
the right thing they sent him a letter
in the letter they say the obama biden
error fbi used democrat-funded
op research russian disinformation
hillary's dirty russian dossier
as well as doctored evidence that would
be the 302s
as a basis to illegally spy on a trump
campaign associate former fbi director
comey caused sensitive information about
his interactions
with president trump to leak to the
media senior fbi employees discussed an
insurance policy
against president trump should he win i
don't think he'll win but if he does we
got the insurance policy
now the revelations about the fbi's
interactions with former national
security adviser lieutenant general
michael flynn
it makes it clear that the fbi's
wrongdoing is worse than previously
known
that's true too these revelations
suggest what is a pattern of misconduct
politicizing at the highest levels of
the obama biden-era fbi
so will director ray we ask you tonight
do you have the goal of cleaning up the
reputation of the world's finest law
enforcement agency
in other words will you hold these bad
actors accountable or
are you going to try and push it under
the rug because director ray
if you don't have the moral courage to
be honest like the attorney general who
did push to get all this out he's
seeking
equal justice he's seeking justice at
the department of justice
if you don't have the courage to hold
these few bad apples accountable
well you got to make way for somebody
who does you need to address the
american people and congress on this
issue
because director ray this is the single
biggest abuse of power in american
history
if this can happen to in this case and
we don't fix it
we're going to lose our country the
american people deserve
answers we have to be able to trust
our fbi our cia those that we
empower with the most powerful tools of
intelligence
that they're not going to turn them on
we the people
we need you to lead that effort if not
clearly the attorney general is leading
that effort
and he's finding the truth wherever he
can find it my sources are telling me
tonight that the reason
the truth is being told is that it is
the a.g
that would be bill barr it is john
durham they are insisting
on special rules no just following the
rule of law
and exposing the truth and cleaning out
all this
garbage and corruption